Speaker 1: Let's go next to Sammi from
New York City. People really shot out
of a cannon. Great to hear people getting
right into their questions. Sammy, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. I hope you can hear me.
Speaker 1: I can hear you beautifully.
Speaker 3: Oh, good. So, yeah, sounds like
things did better last night than we kind
of expected. And I listened to a live stream
that was awesome, as usual. My question is,
and I just tuned in, so I hope someone
else didn't ask this, but my thought is
Trump's going to announce something on November
15th, but I feel like he's going to wait. He
wanted to wait and not announce right away because
he felt like, let's just see, like how all of
these elections turn out. And if things are all
like in his favor, then he would announce that he
was going to run. What do you think? Or is.
Speaker 1: That so? I had that idea as
well. But the thing.
Speaker 3: Is that.
Speaker 1: He's put on he's put so much weight
and made it so obvious. He plans to announce on
Tuesday that even though a bunch of the people he
picked lost, I don't know that he can go back on
his word at this point in time. You know, there
are some Republicans who are saying Trump's time
is over. What he should do on the 15th is say, I'm
not running and endorse Ron DeSantis. That's what
would be best for the Republican Party. Trump's
a huge narcissist, and so it's very hard for
me to imagine that he's going to do that.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Yeah, well, that's true,
too. But the other thing is, like when
he when he would say things like, oh,
I have like I'm going to, you know, I have a
better insurance plan than Obamacare. Yeah.
And it's coming in two weeks. Like, everything's
like it's coming. It's coming. So. I don't know.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think he will announce. I don't
think this is like the health care plan. And then
it'll be interesting to see if and how the polling
shifts and if it's true that it's Trump's for the
taking or if the betting markets are right that
DeSantis has a shot at this thing if he wants it.
Speaker 3: Yeah. The problem with this is that.
Speaker 1: It's just one of the things.
I mean, the problem for DeSantis is.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Trump
can announce Tuesday and that's fine.
DeSantis just got reelected governor.
Speaker 3: Right?
Speaker 1: He can't look
good if he announces a run for the presidency any
time in the next six, eight or even ten months.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I think
that that's a limitation for DeSantis.
Speaker 3: Me too. And even like on the
Florida debate, when Ron DeSantis was asked, look,
are you, you know, tell the Florida people like
you're going to stay the whole governor?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And he wouldn't answer.
He looked like a deer in the headlights.
Speaker 1: He did. He. He seemed to
malfunction and freeze up. Yeah. No, we'll see
that. That's a complication for DeSantis. How
does he smoothly transition into that?
Speaker 3: Yeah. And you know, David,
the last time we spoke, I said, you know, how
amazing I think you are. And and I really you
have really turned me on to politics. Like,
I wouldn't be listening to all of these
other debates if it wasn't
for you, like live streaming.
And I really appreciate that because we.
Speaker 1: Shoot that very much. That's why
we're doing it, hopefully to get people engaged.
Speaker 3: Yeah. And like, we all have to be.
We have to know what's going on.
We have to be informed. Right.
And to make the right decisions. And and I know
you asked me if I would subscribe to the YouTube
channel. I'm subscribed to all three.
Speaker 1: I love it. Sam, thank you
so much for the call. I appreciate.
Speaker 3: It. Of course. Yeah. Yeah.
Have a good day, David. Thank you, too.
Speaker 1: There is the great Sammy from
New York City with some very, very
positive statements, that's for sure.